have they harassed your mom your sister
like other members of your family they
haven't yep absolutely they boxed my mom
my sister they tried to doxy dresses
hassling them for interviews and they're
just trying to put pressure on you
they're trying to put pressure on you
hoping you will crack right but I'm a
consummate professional the biggest the
the best move I made in all of this
where they totally underestimated me is
I predicted this was gonna come and I
leveraged myself against it so when I
knew they were going to cancel me
I kept saying the cancellation's coming
any minute now when they cancel me
they're gonna lie this is what they're
gonna do and I kept saying it so that
when they did it all they just gave me
mass credibility they made me look like
an Oracle and that's the and I wasn't
Oracle I knew it was coming yeah but I
didn't sit there and say please don't
cancel me I said this is what they're
gonna do here's how it's gonna work it's
all a trick and when they do it to me
know it's a lie and then when they did
it obviously they galvanized my viewers
into believing in me even more because I
predicted the future so I was leveraged
very heavily against it but the way it
happened was quite scary I can tell you
right now Richard if you're ever going
to get canceled I can tell you how to
know
because because a few things happen
about a week in advance all right you
know your fault let me know should I
tell you fill me in right so
the first thing they have to do is
control the narrative they have to make
sure that because a bunch of people when
you get canceled are going to hear your
name for the first time you me anyone
right they have to make sure that when
the people hear the name for the first
time those people believe you are bad
and you are evil so they have to paint a
narrative about you so I woke up one day
and 150 different Instagram pages of
lgbtq plus that influence 150 different
pages did a post about me with a caption
which was basically the same or slightly
Rewritten across 150 different pages on
the same day bang an organized attack
from somebody and I was like okay that's
that's strange that about three days
later every teacher's Union from Norway
to Australia to the UK to America
teachers unions were coming out saying
that young boys aren't listening in
school anymore because they keep asking
the teacher what color their Bugatti is
[Laughter]
the teachers unions came for me but the
fact that they all come in absolute
succinct if you ever have like one post
that gets a bunch of traction on you no
big deal but if it's happening in
absolute succinctity with other posts
then some someone is behind it and the
person behind it has the power to cancel
you so there's about five days in a row
of orchestrated hits and then the
cancellation came so they're trying to
paint the narrative yeah like I don't
think people understand how how much
control
um you know these these powers that be
the Matrix whatever is it you know we
want to call it have over information
like even even the Twitter files that
were just released by Elon Musk you know
with what went on with Twitter during
the last election and you're only
starting to see like the tip of the
iceberg like there's more and more
coming from that and that I mean some
would argue that that was information
suppression some would even say that it
um you know manipulated the outcome of
the actual election but they have a lot
more control and they've and they've
been exerting this control for a long
time and you're the first person that
I've seen that's realistically stood up
and said hey you know if you're gonna
[ __ ] on me fine I'm just going to keep
speaking the truth so let's go and that
and that's work for you it's worked very
well because it's giving you a platform
and some interesting uh shows right
it has it certainly worked for me very
very well I think that I am fortunate to
a degree I feel like I've I was doing it
at the right time because now the The
Matrix I believe is starting to crack
like like you said with what elon's
doing for example after this yeah after
this scandemic No One Believes In the
news anymore I feel like I'm doing it at
the right time and the reason I say
right time is not because I'm being so
successful with it but also because
doing at the right time affords some
protection so if I was doing this a few
years earlier when there was no other
uh holes in the ship they would be
trying much harder to put a bullet in my
head but the fact that they have so many
problems now like elon's telling the
truth a whole bunch of people are
telling the truth it's getting diff more
and more difficult for them to wrap it
up you can make one person be quiet but
you can't make thousands be quiet and
that's why I say now is the time for
everyone to speak up because it's the
safest time ever to do so if if if if if
safety was a concern but yeah it's
certainly working out well for me I mean
I I've moved platforms obviously I've
moved over from YouTube to rumble now
and I'm doing very well there I've been
very successful on Rumble uh so that's I
can't complain uh they the the CEO of
Rumble Chris is a true patriot he's a
hero and he came to me in the
cancellation and said you can say
whatever you want but don't care
isn't it yeah yeah man he's an awesome
guy really good guy uh he's Canadian and
um but he's he's certainly for the cause
and lots of other people are moving over
to rumble now as well because they're
understanding that it's a matter of time
until YouTube cuck out on basically
every channel yeah uh so I've been good
there now I'm obviously back on Twitter
uh meta I've not given me anything back
yet but there's already talk about me
being replaced uh sorry being uh
reinstated on Instagram so they're
looking to put me back and I've kind of
I wouldn't want to say I've beaten the
cancellation but the the negative
effects are slowly wearing off the
visual negative effects once I beat all
this imaginary garbage court cases are
gonna come then all in all it's been a
it's been a positive for me and for my
brand but yeah it was also unnecessary
it had to be done because there's
uh I knew that the Matrix only needed a
crack everyone was pissed off with them
for a very long time someone just had to
put a crack in the dam and the pressure
would do the rest and I feel like one of
the cracks that was missing is for
somebody to show that being canceled
doesn't work and if you can show that
then people stop being afraid of their
weapon and then the weapon becomes less
effective and everybody will speak and
will win in the end so
Divine timing perhaps hey guys I really
hope that you enjoyed that short clip if
you did consider supporting the creation
of content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out